- Ils devraient être en train de
fabriquer des moteurs d'avions,
mais les travailleurs
de Rolls-Royce sont en lock-out
depuis un mois et demi.
La question de la rémunération
est au coeur du litige.
Le syndicat affirme que
l'employeur souhaite un gel
salarial pour les deux premières
années de la prochaine
convention collective.
- C'est inacceptable!
C'est un non-respect pour
aucun des salariés ici, là,
t'sais!
- Le coût de la vie a beaucoup
augmenté dans les dernières
années depuis la pandémie.
- Avec toutes les augmentations
qui se font dans l'épicerie,
le gaz, regarde, c'est
des baisses de salaire,
autrement dit, là.
- Au cours de la dernière
décennie, la rémunération
a progressé plus rapidement
que l'inflation au
Les salaires ont augmenté de
23 % dans les milieux syndiqués
et de 30 % dans le
non syndiqués. Des hausses
similaires ont été observées
au Québec. Pendant ce temps,l'ia
consommation a grimpé de 16 %.
Mais la tendance est
en train de s'inverser.
Depuis un an, les salaires
ont augmenté de 3,4 % au Canada,
de 5,5 % au Québec, alors que
l'inflation a bondi de 6,7 %.
Les travailleurs craignent
de perdre leur pouvoir d'achat;
impossible d'échapper
à cette réalité aux tables
de négociations.
CAROLINE SENNEVILLE, prés. CSN
- Les employeurs le voient,
puis le niveau d'augmentation
est quand même plus élevé,
sans nécessairement accoter,
je dirais, parce que l'inflation
est particulièrement haute, là.
- Pénurie de main-d'oeuvre,
hausse du coût de la vie :
la pression monte
les patrons offrent de
meilleurs salaires; sans quoi,
ils risquent de perdre
leurs employés.- Des em- Des ema
a un coût pour une entreprise.
Ça coûte de l'argent,
embaucher des gens, ça coûte
de liX>VIl y a des employeurs qe
comprennent plus que d'autres.
- En février, un nouvau
contrat de travail qui comprend%
pour la première année a été
conclu chez Soucy Internatio
à Drummondville.
Des hausses de 2,5 à 3 %
sont prévues pour les années
suivantes et pourraient
atteindre 4 % si jamais
l'inflation est plus élevée;
un mécanisme d'ajustement
a été inclus.
Selon le syndicat, l'employeur
a fait des concessions
pour retenir ses employés.PAUL s
travailleurs Soucy International
- Je dirais pas qu'il était à
genoux, mais il était conscient
de la problématique parce queou,
on a perdu beaucoup d'expertise,
des employés qui avaient
des 15 ans, 20 ans, presque
30 ans d'ancienneté qui ont
décidé de quitter l'entreprise.
- L'avocat Richard Gaudreault
conseille les employeurs.
Selon lui, ils doivent profiter
de l'occasion pour moderniser
leur entreprise, que ce soit
par l'automatisation ou encore
la réorganisation du travail.
Me RICHARD GAUDREAULT, relations
il, Laveryil, Laveryil, Laveryis
- Ceux qui vont donner des
augmentations de salaire, mais
qui, en contrepartie, vont faire
des gains de productivité vont
probablement se sortir mieux
de la situation actuelle que
ceux qui vont simplement céder à
l'idée d'augmenter les salaires.
- Les trois grandes centralessyt
faire front commun lors de
leurs prochaines négociations
avec le gouvernement dans le
secteur public et elles vonttenn
dans leurs demandes.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Mon